great so our next lecture uh
is by elizabeth meckes from
k-switzerland reserve university but she
is now on
kind of sabbatical at oxford um and the
title of the lecture is projection of
forbidden distributions and measures
where i think it was
iran please elizabeth thanks
thanks thank you so much for the
invitation so um
obviously like like raphael wish we were
all in the same place
um but okay we're not um but anyway i
was i was really looking forward to this
particular opportunity so i'm going to
talk about this work
which is is is not super recent so for a
few of you
in the audience i know you already know
about this this stuff but maybe it's
been
quite a few years since you heard me
talk about it so maybe you forgot um
but but in any case um i've sort of
always thought that or hoped
that there would be some connections
between some of this work and some
aspects of theoretical computer science
um and so i was really excited to get a
chance to talk about this work here and
i hope we can
we can find some connections um okay so
so let's get started so um
oh dear and how do i make the slides
advanced i could
um all right so so marginals are
normally gaussian so here's a
a a phenomenon that's known well
to those who know it well so there's
this general phenomenon
that if you um you have a random vector
in high dimension so
x is a random vector in rd and d is
large then
under some sort of reasonable conditions
on the distribution of x
if you look at if you try to sort of
understand x by
its projections you look at
one-dimensional projections
if you pick a random direction then what
you're going to see is gaussian
so this is just what happens all the
time and statisticians have known this
for a long time and so they kind of
interpret this as gaussian means boring
like that always happens and so you
should look for something non-gaussian
so i have a a picture of of this so this
is actually
from a paper that's about trying to
understand
high dimensional data by drawing
pictures of it of course this is
something that's
that's traditionally been important in
statistics because we like to draw
pictures of things and if you have high
dimensional data you can't draw pictures
of it
and so what should you do if you want to
visualize it
you you can draw projections how do you
pick them and so that's what these guys
were thinking about but i like these
pictures because they illustrate
the point really beautifully um so
probably everybody recognizes what these
pictures are right so this is a cube
um this this one lives in r3 this one is
a cube that lives in r4
r5 or 6 etc and so so you see what
happens um and i formulated
i'll go back and forth a lot between the
the random vector interpretation and the
kind of data
kind of uh viewpoint so when i do that
what i mean is that the random vector
should be thought of as being equally
distributed at these red points
okay so you can think of the red points
as being data points or you can think of
having a random vector and it should
just be
equally likely to be at each of those
points so now
you can still see structure here right
we didn't project very far
so even if there weren't these little
cheater lines here you would still
recognize
what this was and in particular you
would see that you know there were there
was something
some structure to these these points
they weren't just kind of thrown down
at random as it were um and you can kind
of still
still see stuff here um some geometers
claim that they can look at this until
it's a cube i
okay um but but as you keep going right
it gets harder and harder to understand
the picture
um and obviously at some point they
decided that these edges were really
causing more problems than they were
solving so
this last picture doesn't have the edges
but you can see exactly
this sort of phenomenon happening of
course the two-dimensional version but
whatever is the same phenomenon that as
you go higher and higher up and then you
just
project down onto two dimensions you
lose everything you lose all the
structure
and what you see just looks like this
point cloud that just looks like this
gaussian point cloud you don't see
anything anymore
resembling a cube here you can't tell
what the dots came from
was it a cube was it some other shape
you can you can't tell
um so so this is a phenomenon like i
said that's very well understood in data
analysis
but also in geometry and there's been a
lot of interest in
over many years so in statistics this is
called the
the diaconus friedman effect
and it's called that because diaconus
and friedman were certainly not the
first people to notice this
but they proved this beautiful theorem
that kind of made math out of this
observation
in a very nice way so
what they did and one of the things that
was was
at the time quite quite nice about this
is that they started with a data set so
they started with just a deterministic
set of points it wasn't
assumed to come from some kind of random
process with special properties or
anything it was just a set of points
so you start with a set of end points
nrd
they're deterministic and then you
pick a random direction okay so you pick
a random
point uniformly in the unit sphere and
you make this empirical measure so you
put equal mass
at each of the projected points so now
this gives you a way to encode the
projection
of this data onto this you know
one-dimensional space it gives you this
this random object
and then what they proved is that um as
n and d tend to infinity
these measures tend to gaussian measure
weekly in probability
um i think you can actually extract
something a little bit stronger from
their proof but
that's the way they formulated it and so
then the interpretation
was exactly what i said that sort of
this is what always happens you start
with data
you try to understand it if you just
pick a direction at random and project
it
you're probably not going to see
anything because what you always see is
this this gaussian phenomenon
so that was that was from the sort of
statistical point of view but this is
also a phenomenon
that's been studied by a lot of people
in
in geometry and analysis and probability
um and oh i think i spelled his name i
switched the s and the z sorry
um but so so this is a phenomenon that's
been
been long studied in other contexts and
there are a lot of of people who have
contributed to it so um
so this is just kind of a sample theorem
and if it's no longer state of the art i
apologize i had it already coded up to
go on a slide
so i didn't check to see if there's
anything um
fancier at this point but this anyway
gives you the idea of
some of the sort of um quantitative
versions of this kind of
result and it lets me talk a little bit
about this condition um so this is a
theorem of target pop cuff
um so we uh we start with a a random
vector
an xd in our d um and
just assume that its covariance matrix
is the identity so it's just sort of
setting everything in a kind of standard
position
um and then typically like i said in the
diaconus friedman result there's going
to be some kind of condition
um to sort of keep everything from
wandering off too much i mean you need
some some kind of control over where the
mass is for this measure
and so this is some kind of shell
condition
you this thing you expect under these
conditions to be about
like square root of d and so this this
is just
sort of quantifying the extent to which
it deviates from that
and then the result is is this kind of
concentration inequality so that we have
this is the the kolmogorov distance so
you're looking at
the um the projection of this random
vector
onto some direction okay and comparing
that that random variable then to a
gaussian random variable so inside of
here
you know theta is a fixed direction so
we're looking at a fixed projection
we compare it to a gaussian and look at
you know the the probability that this
distance is is bigger than some
some quantity here you get get some
upper bound on this so so this is the
kind of sort of more quantitative
results that that got to be very popular
in understanding um this this kind of
phenomenon
in in this in this nice specific way
so um so this i think really naturally
sort of leads to the question what about
higher dimensional marginals i showed
you a picture
of two-dimensional marginals it's not
very surprising that if we know that
this phenomenon happens very generally
in one dimension like of course it's
two is not very different from one um so
but what about
okay higher dimensional marginals so if
i have a random vector
in high dimensions and it satisfies some
kind of condition so that mass is not
sort of too spread out
um do you think that you know the
five-dimensional marginals or the
17-dimensional marginals are
approximately gaussian well yeah of
course i mean if
if the ambient dimension is really large
um presumably yes
um that that should happen but the kind
of question that i'm much more
interested in
is what if you're interested in k
growing with d
so that is when does it happen
does it still happen if you take a
random vector like this
and you project it onto you know a
subspace that's dimension like log d or
even something like square root of d or
what happens then do you expect to still
see this phenomenon
that all of the projections or most of
the projections look gaussian
or you know where does that break down
obviously it breaks down at some point
because
once you get to the whole thing i mean
you have your original distribution it's
not gaussian
so so where does that happen where does
that change in behavior happen
and so at least in the context that i'm
going to describe in this talk
here is where the the change in behavior
happens is at
um 2 log d over log log d so
um there's a very definitive answer
and i'll say a little bit more about
sort of in what context um i think
that's the answer
and and other contexts um in which
that's not the answer
um but but kind of in in some generality
this is this is some kind of answer
but this is assuming small bowl or
assuming concentration because
and also i wanted to ask about the
previous slide i was a bit surprised
because i mean you're you're assuming
small bowl there and i was wondering how
does it compare to
say the result of i don't even know i
think sodium um assuming concentration
um so i i i don't know
all of the the details of how all of
these these um
there there are people in the audience
who can answer that question way better
than i can
um so yeah your answer to all questions
um so what what i really
wanted to say here so i'm gonna state a
theorem in a second
in which i will say what the condition
is here
um that that makes this the answer for k
and i'll talk some more about other
contexts
with different conditions on on x
that give you different different
consequences i mean there's there's a
lot of
room here um there's a lot of different
parameters that show up and so
depending on what you're trying to
optimize over that can also have an
effect
on sort of what kinds of conditions you
want to put on on x
okay okay
just have some example in mind so what
kind of facts should they visualize
a collection of phantom maybe they've
got the simplex and that measurement is
this a good example just n plus one
yeah actually so yeah i'll talk about
exactly that example in a second so
that's kind of a
an extreme example but yeah i mean it's
good to have in mind for this
examples both in this sort of discrete
setting so it's fine to think about
examples of sort of like
vertices of a polytope or something like
that but where you know you have some
discrete points
um and then or like the pictures i
showed at the beginning but we also
would definitely want to as you know
well um
have examples in mind of where we choose
uniformly from a convex body or
something like that and then this is of
course not the the sharp answer in that
context
there's a question about uh the scaling
with delta on the previous slide the
delta to the fourth in the
in the exponent okay yeah oh it's just
uh can you say something about this
delta the fourth uh
dependence so
no i now at this point i'm sort of
regretting putting this here
this was just meant by way of an example
um i can say something about the
the specific parameter dependence in the
later results but this was
just meant to kind of give give some
context of the kind of result
so like i said i'm not sure if this is i
don't think that this is sharp the the
delta to the for
delta to the fourth dependence i don't
know segregate
okay i'm not sure he's here anymore um i
i don't i'm sorry actually for my i
think you are assuming concentration
here so it's the same result that i'm
just not sure who so
i didn't know that it was due to bobco
foreign but yes
i see right so i mean
there are different ways of stating the
condition of course the one that's in
red i mean there's different ways of
formulating it this is just one way to
formulate it
um okay so
um so i'd like to actually state a
theorem um that that hopefully we'll
sort of get at some of these questions
about what exactly the conditions are
um before i do that let me just
say what we mean when we talk about
random subspaces so it's sort of obvious
uh what we mean when we talk about a
random direction we just have this
sphere and so we pick
pick a direction at random according to
to uniform measure on the sphere
so we do something very similar to
choose a random subspace
um of our d so so we're choosing from
this set of points the the stifle
manifold
so this is just sets of if you like this
is possible orthonormal bases of
k-dimensional subspaces
so i'm just looking at collections um
ordered collections if you want
of um k different points in our d
um whose um pairwise dot products are
are zero and these are unit vectors
so there's a um a rotation invariant
um hard distribute a rotational variant
probability measure
on that set which is you can call heart
measure if you want
um and so here a random point in the
stifle manifold
you can think of exactly and this is
sort of how i think of it is it's the
first
k columns of a hard distributed random
orthogonal matrix
okay so if we pick a an orthogonal
matrix according to harm measure we just
take the first k columns that gives us a
random orthonormal basis
of a subspace and that's how we pick our
um
our random subspaces okay
so um with that said let me let me state
a theorem
so um so here are some conditions on the
vector so x is a random vector in rd
um i want to assume that it's you know
sort of
centered and this is just a scaling
condition
uh this is some kind of you know um
isotropicity condition or some kind of
um
you know rotation and variance condition
i don't want any one direction to stand
out too much so that's what this kind of
condition is doing
and then the the kind of shell
sort of condition here is um similar to
the
the kind of thing that was well this
one's formulated in terms of expectation
so um we look at the
normalized um norm
so single bars are always going to be
the euclidean norm
so we look at the the euclidean norm
squared of our random vector
so its expectation the expectation of
this expression is exactly d
and so we're looking at the extent to
which this um deviates
from d and um it can go
this far so it's it's a fairly weak
condition in terms of um
how how much variation you can have in
the norm
okay so um so then
we we take a theta which is uh set theta
one through theta k so it's a list of of
unit vectors in the stifle manifold
and um x theta is j
then going to be the projection of x
onto the span so this is our way of of
choosing
a random subspace and then projecting x
onto the random subspace
so um so there's showing up our
expression where we have delta log d
over log log d
um and delta can be somewhere between
zero and two
so um so there's a lot of stuff here so
um the the point is that you have
under these conditions that you have so
this is the bounded lipschitz
distance so um distance measured by by
bounded lipschitz test functions
uh the bounded lipsticks distance from
the projection to the corresponding
gaussian measure
is bounded by this epsilon epsilon is
going to zero with d
not very fast this c can be made like
kind of explicit but
it's small um so that's going to zero
very slowly
but it is going to zero as d tends to
infinity
um this happens with fairly high
probability
okay so this is the this is the failure
um probability
uh for this condition so for everybody
except in this bad set here which is
very small
you have that the bounded lipschitz
distance between
the projected uh vector and the gaussian
vector is uh is something that's bounded
by this quantity which tends to zero as
d tends to infinity
okay so uh so that's the the main result
and um and the proof for this result
works
as long as um delta is strictly smaller
than two
so then of course the the natural
question is is that
actually the right answer um what if you
tried to take delta bigger what would
happen
and so this is exactly uh bar's example
that he was asking about earlier so if i
take x to be uniform
among this this point set here
then and suppose i consider
c to be some constant which is strictly
bigger than 2 and look at a subspace
of of this
this dimension so c log d over log log d
where c is strictly bigger than 2. um
so then uh then you can very easily come
up with the lipschitz test function that
shows you
that the projections of this vector are
not close to gaussian
and it's basically just sort of for
volume considerations
so you um so this is the the lipschitz
test function so you look at the
projections of these points onto your
subspace
and then you just measure the distance
from a point in
in um in uh
e to those projected points and so you
you compare that to one you take the
positive part
so the point is that this is a function
which is equal to
one um on these points and then it drops
away to zero
linearly um
so now this is a function with founded
lipschitz norm bounded by one
and um but just from
purely volume considerations if you you
take the integral of this test function
with respect to gaussian measure
it tends to zero um in a in a space of
dimension
c log d over log log d or c is bigger
than two um
so that's just a sort of asymptotic
computation um so you can see then that
the bounded lipschitz distance in this
case between any projection
of these points and gaussian is about
one
and so you don't get um this approximate
gaussian phenomenon
at this point there's a question from
clement in the chat
about the the scaling of epsilon with k
in the in your main theorem the scaling
of
epsilon with k
well i mean they so both of them i mean
there's implicit scaling but
i sorry i can't see the question is it a
specific question or is it just what's
up with that
how does epsilon scale with k so well it
doesn't exactly right they're both
they're both expressed in terms of of d
so k is um
is delta log d over log log d and delta
is a fixed constant
it doesn't depend on anything it's just
somewhere between zero and two
epsilon so um the the c
does depend on delta of course i guess
the question is about when k is much
smaller than log d over log log d
like if k is log log d oh then it's much
easier
yeah then then it's fine um i i don't
know off the top of my head
exactly what epsilon looks like in that
case but but getting this kind of
convergence is much easier
when when k is of smaller order
um yeah yeah so this is sort of like
trying to get it at really the the limit
of of when things change but um yeah if
you wanted to
so this is something that i was i was
going to talk about a little bit later
but
one of the things that's important to
remember about this theorem is that
everything was optimized to try to
figure out exactly how high you could
push k
and see this phenomenon at all so it's
an open
sort of area to look at to see if that
wasn't your primary concern but you sort
of had
more specific things that you wanted
here like there were certain kinds of
certain distance estimates that mattered
to you um
how would these things change it's going
to be a different optimization problem
and so
you could you could dig back into the
proof and see what the proof gave you in
that case
but this proof is optimized to try to
make this number as big as possible
okay so um right so
so this is just sort of summarizing that
that this is this um
cutoff in which you sort of see the
phenomenon for sure um
for for a large measure of subspaces
um below below this sort of critical
cut off and above it you might not
all right so um so i know this is a this
is a fairly mixed audience so for some
people this is
you know they learned this when they
were five but for lots of people they
maybe didn't
so let me say a little bit about
toretsky's theorem and what it is
and and what i sort of see is the
connection here
so um so and i formulated this in terms
of slices instead of projections which
is sort of unfortunate but
okay um so you you have um in foreski's
theorem you have a
norm so you put an arbitrary norm on rd
not arbitrary anymore so i'll do a
linear transformation so that the
maximum volume ellipsoid inside the unit
ball
is is the round sphere or as a dilate of
the sphere
is just to to make it easier to look at
the statement
um so so we do a linear transformation
to make things rounder
from the get go and then
[Music]
then the theorem is that for epsilon
positive fixed there's some rescaling
of the norm and um
and some constant depending only on
epsilon so that if you look at
um at subspaces that of dimension log d
times some some constant which only
depends on this epsilon but is
not dependent on the dimension um then
if you choose a random subspace
uh of r d of this this dimension
um the the norm so with with high
probability
the this arbitrary norm that you started
with will look very much
like the um the euclidean norm
okay so that's that's uh most
most k dimensional subspaces of this
norman space look like
k dimensional euclidean space so
so just to kind of hit you over the head
with it um
the the analogy is you know in both in
both cases
you have rn and then you have some
additional structure
that you put on it so in davarzky's
theorem we put a norm um
in in our context here we put a
probability measure
in either case you know you have a sort
of especially nice kind of very
invariant very symmetric
uh way of of doing this um and
then um the the sort of conclusion of
both cases is that if you reduce the
dimension far enough
then um typically what happens is that
all of that original structure is lost
and what you see is this sort of
reference your old friend um you see the
euclidean norm or
you see the um the gaussian measurement
so um so let me say i i want to sort of
say some things about the proof because
they um they touch on their
a lot of things like things that rafa
was talking about earlier
and uh things that are relevant um to
the
to the workshop but let me mention one
other thing
um which is interesting in the sort of
circle idea of ideas around foretsky's
theorem
um so this there's this idea of
deforetsky dimension
so that is under some extra assumptions
on the norm
um it may be that the the
subspaces on which you see this sort of
universal roundness are actually larger
than what's predicted by the the general
theorem
so there's this um result of figuelin
and strauss and vitale millman
so that if you have a bionic space with
co-type
q then you get subspaces
of polynomial dimension in the ambient
dimension which are approximately
euclidean
so i don't want to talk at all about
what cotype is or anything it's a
geometric condition on the norm
um but but the point is that you can
with this extra condition on the norm
you can have um polynomial behavior
of these subspaces that look roughly
euclidean
rather than the logarithmic behavior we
saw before
and just as by way of another example so
shariq
looked was looking at spaces with
bounded volume ratio
and similarly found in that case you can
get nearly euclidean subspaces of quite
large
dimension relative to the ambient
dimension of the space
um so so that's an interesting
phenomenon and it's one that hasn't
really been explored very much in this
context um
so so boaz's result
on the the random vector be
having a log concave distribution which
i want to emphasize preceded
the work here so that that work was done
first and he considered
um random vectors in nrd that had log
concave distributions
and was able to show that most
projections are close to gaussian
and in that case the behavior of the the
projection dimension and the ambient
dimension is is polynomial
um so so there the sort of this
additional assumption
um of having this log concavity you know
again makes a big difference and you you
move from this
logy type behavior of the the subspaces
to the um to something polynomial
um so i think it would be interesting to
kind of look at at other possible
examples you know what other
what other conditions are there on on
random vectors
that change this kind of behavior can
you say more
in in the same way that you can here
okay so um so i do want to say a little
bit like i said about
um about the proof so let me
let me sort of outline how it works um
so what the the basic approach
is to um to do something that's
sort of very familiar and kind of
statistical mechanical concept
contexts you um where they have this
terminology of referring to the sort of
annealed setting in the quenched setting
so the annealed setting is otherwise
known as the easier setting
and what you do there is so what we
really want to understand
is when this x is is random
and then when theta is fixed and we'd
like to be able to say
what happens for a very large measure of
theta but instead of
going straight there instead we um
we let theta be random and independent
of x
so we're really looking at kind of the
averaged out situation
over all choices of subspace um
so so you want to show then that this
thing
is approximately gaussian and that um
that's done with steins method
um okay and then the the next step is to
get rid of
some of that randomness so you
um so you can look at this
uh projection of your your random vector
x onto a specific subspace
and compare that to the projection of x
onto a random subspace
so this is the the annealed thing where
you're you're averaging over all
possible subspaces you'd have a really
random subspace
this is where you have a fixed subspace
so these are both k dimensional random
vectors
and so you can compare them in a metric
so you can look at their bounded loop
shit's distance
and that's a random variable so it's a
function right of this theta
so it's a it's a nice function on the
stifle manifold
and so now if i treat that function as a
random variable by putting
um the the har measure on the sheafl
manifold
i can ask about the expectation of that
distance okay so this is the
quantity that that i've sometimes
referred to as the the average distance
to average okay so this is the average
doubt super averaged out version
of the projection and then we're asking
on average how far
is a specific projection from the
average projection
all right um so so that's the question
and this is kind of the
the most involved part of the proof um
and the way this
this works is by interpreting this
bounded lips it's distance as a supreme
of a stochastic process
indexed by test functions um and then
using concentration of measure
um and and um something like like
dudley's entropy bound so this is very
closely related to some things that rafa
was talking about
earlier this morning okay and then
finally
we want to get rid of this is just the
average distance to average um
and then ultimately we would like to
just say what's the typical distance to
average right so we want to look at a
projection
of of x onto some subspace
and um and then
um compare it to the average and we want
to say that sort of typically that's
small
and this this is actually pretty easy
and this follows from concentration of
measure on the stifle manifold
um so this is another one of those cases
where sort of understanding the average
itself is considerably harder than
understanding the concentration
um just because they're high-powered
tools to get at this
okay so that's the outline um that's the
basic approach
um so let me say a little bit more about
the the various steps
so first step one um i said this is with
with steins method
um and it's uses this this exchangeable
pairs
um approach to stein's method with this
kind of um continuous symmetry group
acting which is what we have here
um so here's a kind of rough um
yeah i don't know why i put all those
pauses in um
so here's a kind of rough uh version of
of what the
the abstract theorem that you use here
says
so you start with a random vector um
that you
uh you think is approximately gaussian
so that's what we have and
you build a family of exchangeable pairs
using the
the symmetry of the just somehow using
exploiting some symmetry that this
distribution has
you sort of make a small random change
so that this pair is exchangeable
and and you quantify that change
by some some small parameter which you
can then send to zero
so there are three conditions that you
have to check to apply the theorem
here they are roughly so you want to
have
this kind of conditional expectation of
this
this difference is supposed to be
proportional to the sky that you started
with and then you have some kind of
conditional covariance thing that's
supposed to be
basically constant and you have some
third moment that you have to estimate
so you sort of check through these
conditions and if everything works out
then you get that um that this this
thing that you started with
is is approximately gaussian in a
quantified uh way so you get an explicit
error term
so um for this step of the proof
remember we're doing things in a very
average sort of way so we're taking a
uniform
random point in the steeple manifold
independent of x
and then we um we take x to be our
random vector and
and we look at the projection of x onto
that subspace
and so then you um i'll just say you
know
how you how you make the exchangeable
pair and then i'll tell you that you do
some computations after that and
and it all works out um so so
this is this is i'm mostly showing you
this so you can see
why the annealed case is so much easier
so because what you really exploit is
the randomness here
the randomness here we understand really
really well because this is just coming
from
har measure on the orthogonal group
whereas over here we don't understand
the randomness at all that's the point
is it's supposed to be fairly arbitrary
um so to to make this exchangeable pair
um you you do a little random rotation
in in the measure here which is supposed
to be rotation and variance so that
should be fine right
so um here's our uh our theta
theta 1 through theta k and um
and then what you do is you have a
little rotation
by epsilon in a two-dimensional so this
is like in the
space spanned by the first two um
standard basis vectors and then you
conjugate that by a random orthogonal
matrix so that gives you
a a rotation in a random subspace and so
then
you rotate each of these theta vectors
by the same thing and that gives you
a different element of the the shield
manifold and this pair is exchangeable
so with that then you just stick
everything into
the previous slide and it tells you um
what you have to compute
and you try to compute it i mean try to
estimate the quantities that show up and
it
mostly comes down to computing moments
of entries of random orthogonal matrices
and then at the end of the day this is
what you get so you've got to bound on
the bounded lips it's distance
from the projected version of x
onto the distance between that and
gaussian
and and this is what it looks like so
here you're seeing that kind of um shell
condition showing up so the
the deviations in the norm of the your
your random vector and um you see the
projection dimension and then the
ambient dimension as well
so um so fine so that's that tells you
then that in the sort of super averaged
setting everything works out fine so
um so where does measure concentration
come in that sort of does everything
else
in a way or that's sort of the crucial
tool for all of the other
parts of the proof so
first of all what's the metric
on on the stifle manifold so
this is just this sort of natural l2
type
thing so you compare the different
different unit vectors in one of these
points remember these are
sequences of k points and you compare
them
just one by one and take this kind of l2
metric um so then um
i think this this first first appeared
in the the book of millman and
schechtmann
although it um it's very closely related
to work of of gromof melman
um so you have um sub-gaussian
concentration of lipschitz functions
on the stupal manifold um so in this
sort of very familiar
way right so you have some some
lipschitz function on the stifle
manifold
and um and you get the subgaussian
concentration showing up here and
there's the lipsense
okay so so the point is that the
distance
um so the distance itself if you look at
this thing um as a function of theta
so you look at the projection of x onto
a particular subspace spanned by a point
in the stifle manifold you compare that
to a gaussian measure
and you compare it in the bounded lips
it's distance this is a real valued
function
of theta and it's it's easy to show that
that real valued function of theta is a
lipschitz function
and so this is basically the whole
content of step three is that because
something like this is a lipschitz
function we get concentration
for free from from this this result okay
so really
the job the the job that we have to do
here
is to actually estimate that the average
of that that function so
um just writing things out in terms of
the the definition you have
the um the bounded lipschitz distance
again from a projection onto a fixed
subspace
you compare that to the projection onto
a random independently chosen subspace
and then you take the mean of that
so um that's exactly this quantity
you're comparing
um with bounded lipschitz test functions
the expected value of this guy
um where theta is random versus the
expected value of the sky where theta is
fixed
so um so you define the stochastic
process
xf um in this way so this is a centered
stochastic process just by fubini's
theorem
and then um what you want
is the i really should have called this
yf sorry
um with that too many x's all right so
this is not related to this
this x here um this is a new stochastic
process for each
test function i get a different random
variable right so i'm thinking if this
is a random variable because
i'm computing a conditional expectation
here and i get a function of theta
this is just a number right so so this
is a random variable
and i get one for each test function and
so that gives me a stochastic process
indexed by the unit ball of this space
so the measure concentration that i was
mentioning on the previous slide
which does me so many favors another
thing that it does
is it shows you that this stochastic
process here satisfies the subgaussian
increment condition
so um right because x f minus x g so
that would be an increment of the
process
it's actually x f minus g because
everything in sight is linear and the
in the test functions so you get
immediately
that you have um this sub-gaussian
increment condition
for the stochastic process and the um so
there's the epsilon squared that's the
sub-gaussian and the
the notion of comparison then between
the test functions
is scaled by the dimension d and um
and that's that's sort of the crucial
crucial thing
so um i didn't know that rafa was
already gonna do this so i'll
show it to you again so so the idea
is to use dudley's dudley's
entropy bound so if you have a
stochastic process
that satisfies a subgaussian increment
condition like the one we have here
then you get a bound for the expected
supremum
in terms of these these covering numbers
so
n t delta epsilon is the covering number
so you want to cover the metric space t
which is the indexing set here um
[Music]
this is the metric on t and you want to
cover it with balls of radius epsilon
count how many it takes take the log
take the square root and so on
so um so that's uh that's the
the um entropy bound and our process
satisfies this kind of condition we hear
the delta the metric
is the bounded lipschitz distance
divided by the square
root of d so um
so that's the kind of process we have so
um the naive thought at that point would
be all right
well so here is
um our our t our metric space which is
indexing our stochastic process
it's sub gaussian let's just crank it
out let's um let's do
do dudley and we can't because um this
is an infinite dimensional space and
so this these numbers are all infinity
so you can't just do it
um right right from there um but it's
it's sort of not
not that bad and i didn't didn't want to
get into the technicalities
um on the slides but let me just say
um so the idea is that
so first you have to make some kind of
truncation argument that's very standard
um but then you can approximate these
lipschitz test functions
by just considering their values at um
so you put like a mesh
to put a grid into the domain and you
look
at the values of the functions just at
those grid points and then you
interpolate linearly in between
so that is you can reduce your space
from being this infinite dimensional
space
to finite dimensional space where you're
looking at test functions but their
their values are determined just by the
values of these grid points
and so then you have a lot of choices to
make so i said that you had a
there's a truncation so you have to you
have a truncation parameter you also
have to decide how fine to make this
grid
and the choice of that of course um
determines
what the dimension of this finite
dimensional space
that your uh your your metric space uh
indexing space is is um living in
and so then when you you have to
estimate these covering numbers of
course those
are going to depend on the
dimensionality
that you choose here and so there's a
very delicate balance
at this point of keeping track of these
various different parameters that you
introduce
and and trying to optimize over um
over the the different choices that you
have to make um
so so you make some choices and uh
and you get to to this point that the
this average distance to average can be
bounded
in this way so you see the the
projection dimension showing up
in various ways here and also the
ambient dimension
um so just just kind of to summarize um
we have that uh that this uh
bounded lipsticks distance the annealed
version um
to the gaussian you bound with stein's
method in this way and this is sort of
where this condition about
concentration for the norm comes in
we have a concentration of this guy
about its mean coming from the
concentration phenomenon on the steeple
manifold or or if you like just on the
orthogonal group
and then ultimately um this band
on the the average distance to average
uh through through the argument that i
was just outlining
and then um at the end of the day you
can you can choose k
and epsilon in this way and c depends in
some
boring way um on on delta
and and that completes the proof so
that's it
thank you very much elizabeth for this
talk uh are there any questions
elizabeth i have one question
um usually when you put what historian
and things like that
you don't really get a dimension which
is just a sharp threshold because you
get the dimension up to a constant but
somehow you manage not to lose a
constant
in the in the dimension rather than
think two log d over log
in two is really sharp how could it be i
you know i i have no idea i mean that
was a total surprise to me
um and that you know i worked out what
what the proof did and it
it worked up to two and then i figured
that this this simplex example was a
good candidate to
to show me sort of i did not expect it
to actually fail
immediately past too so i do not have a
deep reason that that happens i
i wonder if there is one i i mean
probably what's that so you had some
estimate in you to choose
depending on delta what do you see
what's the battle neck what's the
name of the computation that you had in
the previous slide
what do you see that it does not work
above 2 somehow can you see quickly
beyond any oh no no
it's i mean it's no you can't see it
quickly okay
all right well okay that's a miracle
yeah i mean it's just weird i don't know
okay
any other questions
no i'm looking around me but we should
look in the camera
okay no further questions let's thank
elizabeth again
and the conference begin i resume it's
2pm pacific time
thank you